في الشوارع وافتراضيا فوق القمم وفي اعماق
البحر السعوديون يحتفلون بيوم العلم وازمه
افلاس بنك سيليكون فاليتو تسيطر على
العناوين عالميا وفي تفاعلكم نبسطها لكم
وغناء في مقبره يثير جدلا في السودان اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
احتفل ملايين السعوديين امس بيوم العلم
هذه المناسبه الوطنيه لصدر امر ملكي
بخصوصها فامر الملك سلمان بتخصيص يوم 11
مارس من كل عام للعلم الوطني وتسميه هذا
اليوم بيوم العالم وهذا الاحتفال جاء
انطلاقا من قيمه العلم الممتده عبر تاريخ
الدوله السعوديه منذ تاسيسها واللي بيرمز
بشهاده التوحيد في وسطه الى رساله السلام
والاسلام والسيف طبعا بيرمز للقوه والانفه
وعلو الحكمه والمكانه ووزارات ومؤسسات
حكوميه نظمت احتفالات بالمناسبه تضمنت رفع
العلم وتشغيل اغاني وطنيه هذا غير
المؤسسات الخاصه كمان اللي احتفلت
بالطريقه نفسها وطبعا الطلاب والطالبات في
المدارس احتفلوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كنت ترى
[موسيقى]
ومجادك وا
ونه مقاطع الاحتفالات والفيديوهات التي تم
تداولها في يوم العالم كثيره لكن يمكن
اللي كانوا ملفتين اكثر من غيرهم مقاطع من
قمم جبال عاليه في مختلف بقاع المملكه رفع
عليها المواطنين العلم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
تم رفع العالم السعودي في يوم العلم 11
مارس 20 23
وفي اعلى قمه جبل الطارقي ارتفاع تقريبا
930 متر مربع
[موسيقى]
روحي وما ملكك
الحبيب وهل اح
ي وغير القمم كمان في الاعماق في شباب
سعوديين غاصو حاملين العلم محتفله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
موضوع احتفالات يوم العلم ومقاطعها وصورها
الدوله السعوديه بشكل واسع ويمكن من اكثر
المواضيع اللي تم تداولها صور بتظهر تاريخ
تطور العالم السعودي من بدايه الدوله
السعوديه الى يومنا هذا
الاحتفالات بيوم العالم كمان تضمنت تدشين
موقع الكتروني رسمي للعلم السعودي في كل
التفاصيل اللي يحتاجها اي احد عن العلم
وتم كمان تدشين حساب على تويتر ليوم
العالم جامع الاف المتابعين وبيغرد الحساب
بمعلومات عن العلم السعودي ومن المقاطع
الملفته حقيقه لنشرها الحساب والفيديو
اللي راح تشوفوه الان واللي مرفق معه كمان
كتيب بيتضمن بروتوكول وضوابط وارشادات
استخدام العالم
العلم لها احترام وبروتوكولاته ما يجوز
ابد تنكيسه ولا يعلى عليه علم ومكانه دايم
مكان الشرف ولاننا نفخر به علمنا حاضر فيه
كل المناسبات والمحافل في المنصات
والمكاتب وواجهه المباني وحتى السيارات
والسفن وكلها لها ضوابط وتعليمات وحتى في
العرض السعودي
لها تقاليده ومكانه وحاملها يكون في صف
المؤدي شايل للعلم بشماله والعلم على كتف
الايمن وحتى طيب العلم لازم يكون بشكل
لائق وخطوات محدده مثلا يكون في مكان
مناسب وما تدلى اطرافه وتلمس الاخ هذا
علمنا وهذه بعض ارشاداته وما يكفي اللي
عرفته اطلع الحين على الدليل الارشادي
لاستخدام علم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وتصفح الموقع الالكتروني واحتفل وافخر
بعلمنا باللي يليق فيه ويعكس هيبته
بنك امريكي لغايه كم يوم فاتو كان بنك
كثير ناس حول العالم ما حتى عمرهم سمعوا
فيه لكن بين يوم وليله نمنا وصحينا لقينا
اشهر بنك في العالم
والاخبار عنه صراحه
فالسلطات الامريكيه قفلت البنك ووضعته تحت
وصايه المؤسسه الفيدراليه لتامين الودائع
يعني بالمختصر البنك اعلن افلاسه وبيقعد
هذا الافلاس اكبر فشل مصرفي واول افلاس
لبنك امريكي من وقت الازمه الاقتصاديه في
2007 2008
البنك مختص في قطاع التكنولوجيا ومعظم
عملاء وشركات ناشئه ولمن زاد سعر الفائده
اعلن انه بيسعى لزياده راس المال بسرعه
لتامين سيوله كافيه قام عملاء البنك خافوا
كلهم يسحبوا فلوسهم والبنك ما عنده فاعلن
افلاسه ماذا يعني ابسط واسهل وصف نقدر
نقول لكم اياه
لحظه
على كل المنصات ما لها سيره الا افلاس بنك
السيليكون فالي ومعنا هذا الشيء وخطورته
وتاثيره على الاقتصاد في العالم وصراحه
كميه تفاصيل اقتصاديه معقده وفي نفس الوقت
تكعب وكمان غير مفهومه للناس اللي يعني ما
لهم في الاقتصاد فاحنا قلنا اننا بحاجه
نتكلم مع احد يبسط لنا الموضوع ويشرح لنا
اولا ليش موضوع افلاس البنك هذا خطير الى
هذه الدرجه وقالب الدنيا قد كده وثانيا هل
فعليا مثل ما يقال انه يعني هذا
بازمه في العالم كله يعني هل المفروض
الناس تخاف لكل الدول جلسه تطلع كده
وبتطمن الناس على اقتصادهم لتبسيط الموضوع
وفهموا بشكل اكبر معنا من جده المحلل
المالي عبد الله مشاط اهلا فيك معنا
عبدالله يعني لما الواحد يشوف حجم الضجه
اللي صايره على البنك الان يصير يقول طب
انا عمري في حياتي ما سمعت فيه هذا البنك
اصلا ليش قد كده ما سمعنا فيه اذا هو قد
كده مهم معامل ازمه يعني
مساء الخير ساره ومساء الخير لجميع
المستمعين والمشاهدين وسعيدين مره اخرى
انه معاك رغم انه الموضوع الصراحه يساره
يزعل المستمعين وللاسف يعني كان حادثه
مؤسفه بس لازم تتعلم ونتكلم عنها
فللامانه بنك سيليكون فالي اتوقع الغالبيه
العظمى من الناس ما عمرهم سمعوا فيه رغم
انه يعتبر البنك رقم 16 في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من ناحيه حجم الاصول
وبس عشان اقرب الصوره للمستمع وللمستمعه
حجم اصول البنك يعادي الاجمالي اصول البنك
الراجحي في السعوديه فنحن فعليا بنتكلم
على بنك عملاق بكل ما تعنيه فليس بنك صغير
وله بنك اقليمي فاللي صار مع بنك سيليكون
فالي انه فعليا خلال يومين انفتحت ابواب
الجحيم والسهم هبط من مستويات عاليه جدا
268 دولار الى مستويات الواحد واربعين
شفناه تخوف هلع كبير بانيك الكل كان
مرموقه بهذا الشكل غالبا يعني سوف يصل الى
كل الناس الموجودين في السوق فاللي صار
بدا الضغط على السهم بدا تهور وسار شيء
يسمى في عالم المال والاموال اللي هو
باختصار عندما يذهب الغالبيه العظمى من
الناس للبنك من اجل المطالبه في اموالهم
وكلنا اموالنا موجوده في بنوك والبنوك
طبعا لن تضعها جانبا يجب انه دائما
تستثمرها
انها اموال اكثر ما عنده هذا الفلوس كله
عشان يعطيها البنك صحيح صحيح البنك جزء
كبير من شغله انه ياخذ الاموال من
المودعين ويحاول قدر الامكان انه يطلع
عليه عائد من اجل انه البنك نفسه يستفيد
في كارثه بنك سيليكون فالي اللي تسبب في
هذا الهلع سواء من بيت او من كل الموجودين
في تويتر اليوم انه البنكر ارتكب خطا
جوهري قبل سنتين قرر البنك انه جزء كبير
من اموا تقريبا اربعين في الميه ثمانين
مليار دولار تساوي ثلاثمائه مليار ريال
قرر انه يضعها في في سندات تدعى
عائد واحد ونصف بالمئه هذا عائد كان يعتبر
ممتاز في وقت كانت الفائده فيه صفريه اللي
صار انه الفيدرالي رفع الفائده من مارس
والان الفائده فوق الاربعه ونص في المئه
ففعليا العائده اللي كان بيحصل على البنك
اصبح بلا قيمه واصبح علم البنك يحاول
يستفيد من اموال الناس اصبح العكس يعني
كان في خطا استراتيجي من البنك وبعدين
صارت الامور هذه كلها طيب الان هذه يعني
احنا حندخل في ازمه عالميه يعني يعني
الناس ايش لازم تعمل الان ايش لازم يخافوا
حاليا يوجد اكثر من اربعين الف حساب
اغلبها لمؤسسات اما ستار او شركات موجوده
بسيليكون
اودعت امواله في بنك سيليكون اللي هو باسم
سيليكون
البنك الفيدرالي الامريكي ما بعد 2008 قام
ببعض التشريعات اللي تحمي الى مبلغ 250
الف دولار هذه مؤمنه بنسبه 100% يوم
الاثنين اي شخص عنده 250 الف دولار سوف
يحصل عليها طب السؤال الاهم في حال مثلا
اودعت اكثر من 250 الف دولار ماذا سوف
يحصل لاموالي اي شخص سوف يعوض باول 250
الف دولار فوريا ومن ثم سوف يحصل على
وثيقه تثبت باقي ملكيه للاموال
هذا المبلغ لاحقا هذا بالنسبه للناس اللي
في الحساب اللي عندهم حسابات في البنك طيب
بس تاثيره العامل لدرجه يعني البيت الابيض
جالس بيطلع بيقول لا الامور تمام يا جماعه
انه
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه ويعني في تطمينات
عالميه من دول يعني وبريطانيا برضو كمان
جلسه بتطمن
[موسيقى]
بيهدد بازمه مصرفيه كارثيه انه حتكون في
عهد بايدن على العموم حنتابع يعني القصه
ونشوف
التداعيات زي ما قلت انت الموضوع فيه كثير
من العامل الهلع والخوف يعني بياثر فيها
على العموم نحن بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كان معنا من جده المحلل مالي عبد الله
مشاط شكرا لك
اهلا من جديد ضجه كبيره اشعلها مقطع فيديو
في السودان مع انه الفيديو نفسه متصور فيه
اريتريا والمقطع بيظهر فيه رجل ام القبر
محمد احمد سرور احد عمالقه الفن والابداع
في السودان
[موسيقى]
المسيح
تلعب والعشوق تعبان
الشخص اللي شفتوه رجل سوداني كان واقف عند
جبر الفنان السوداني محمد احمد سرور اللي
بيعتبر عميد الفن السوداني وتوفي عام 1947
وكان جالس بيغني كلمات احد اغاني الفنان
الراحل الشهيره وبيستخدم اله الرقه اللي
برضو كان مشهور فيها الراحل ويبدو من
المقطع انه كان معاه شخص اخر وبيصوره
المقطع انتشر من هنا واشتغل طبعا الجدل من
هنا ناس شافت المقطع في انتهاك لحرمه
الميت وانه ما يصير الغنى في المقابر وبما
انه متعب نفسه ورايح يزور قبره في بلد
تانيه كان لازم يدعي له او يقراوا القران
مو يوقف ويغني وفي ناس تانيه شافت انه لا
عادي رجل كان بيحيي ذكرى الراحل عبر فنه
اللي قدمه وفي ناس ثالثه قالت انه الجماعه
الغنى الجزائري هذا معروف كعاده او كعاده
عند السودانيين في التراث على النحو
السائد في المناحات والمراسي والاغاني
الجنائزيه والمعادي ما فيها شيء بغض النظر
عن الغناء وعن تباين الاراء اللي صايره
فحقيقه يعني ملفت في القصه وفاء الرجل
لانه نحن بنتكلم عن فنان توفي سنه 1947
يعني بنتكلم عن 77 سنه وفوق كل هذا متعني
ورايح بلد تاني اصلا يعني عشان هذه
الزياره كلهم لكن على العموم بعد الجدل
الكبير هذا انتشر على واتساب في السودان
فويس نوت لرجل قال انه هو الظاهر في
الفيديو وبيرد على الجدل
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
انا ايوب محمد الحاج الذي غنى على غبر
الحاج محمد احمد سرور
زرت قبره بغبره باسمره رفعته له الفاتح
وترحمت عليه وقرات سوره الاخلاص 11 مره
واهدايتها الى روحي سائلا المولى ان يغفر
له ويسكنه الفردوس الاعلى
ثم غنيت اغنيه للتوثيق
ولا اكون اول من غنى على غبر سرور ماذا في
ذلك قامت الدنيا وقعدت
[موسيقى]
مناخ سويديه شابه معروفه بجدليتها من وقت
ما بدات نشاطها وهي طفله لمراهقتها وحتى
الان في شبابها لها اسلوبها في الاحتجاج
الكثير ناس بتعارضوا وما بتحبوا اسم في
العناوين ولكن مو بسبب احتجاج ولا دعوه
لاحتجاج بخص التغير المناخي ولكن السبب
تغريده تغريده قديمه كانت نشرتها في عام
2018 التغريده كانت مشاركه فيها مقال
لموقع اسمه وعنوانها عالم او عالم مناخ
كبير البشريه ستنقرض ان لم نصلح التغير
المناخي بحلول 20 23 والتقرير بيشرح
تصريحات منسوبه لعالم كبير بيقول ان
البشريه لو ما وقفت استخدام الوقود
الاحفوري رح تنقرض خلال خمس سنوات يعني
السنه اللي نحن فيها الان ويبدو في ناس مع
دخلتنا عشرين 23 تذكروا التغريده وقالوا
يدخلوا يردوا عليها لكن انصدموا لما ما
لقي تغريده اثر في حسابها وبشويه اتضح انه
قريتها مساحه التغريده واخر مره انشافت في
حسابها كانت في سبعه الشهر عموما حبايب ما
قصروا فيها وعلى تويتر نزلوا تغريدات
ويقولوا لها فين التغريده وليش مسحتيها
واهو 20 23 جات ومنقرضنا
للتذكير بس مشاهدينا انه كثار من معارضين
ما بينكروا ابدا الاحتباس الحراري
والخطورته لكن شايفين جريتا يعني اوفر
شويه
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لختام حلقتنا وراح
نختمها من مكان ما بداناها اليوم احتفالات
يوم العلم السعودي فالفنان الكبير راشد
الماجد هو كمان احتفل بيوم العلم عبر طرح
اغنيه خاصه اترككم مع مقطع منها واعود
والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في امان الله
نرجع
وراء السعودي من قدم راح اعلم اللي ما درى
بارواحنا نفدى العالم
ما نرجع وراك
[موسيقى]
راح على داره مرواح
نا بنختل العالم
[موسيقى]
ما نرجع
راح اعلم اللي ما درى بروح انا نفدى
العالم
[موسيقى]